I'm here today to talk about fundraising
or as you probably think of it the other
F word because if you want to change the
world you have to know how to pay for it
I'm not talking about being a good
person you can do that for free I'm
talking about if you want to create
something start something galvanize a
community improve the lives of others
run for office every day great ideas die
on the vine because they don't have
capital to get off the ground and all of
the work the thought the vision that
goes into the idea isn't worth much if
you can't pay your bills and while most
of the greatest social movements in
history were powered purely by an idea
and people's belief in that idea real
change in impact require resources real
people do this work they need real
change real impact and resources to
actually make it happen the people that
believe in this work have to have the
support and the resources to do it
that's where I come in I get essential
resources into the hands of people and
visionaries on the front lines doing
work that matters we spend the majority
of our waking hours working we spend
more time working than we do with our
loved ones
so I decided early on that I have to
love my work and it has to add value and
while I would love to be one of these
people who spearheads you know social
change from the ground up the thing I
realized early on in my nonprofit career
is that the thing I'm good at
the thing I'm really good at is raising
money and I love it I think it is a
privilege to work alongside bold
ambitious optimistic leaders and the
organization's they serve so I teach
people how to do the thing I'm good at
because the more people that learn how
to be good at my end of this work the
more work will get done and I teach
everyone I teach CEOs and presidents and
boards of directors and edie's I teach
development directors and all sorts of
teams and
prophet knew these social change agents
and candidates I teach anyone that wants
to do something extraordinary how to
fund their dream my dream is that there
will be more people like me doing this
work well and that development will be
an undergraduate course at universities
so that fundraising animals like me will
find this job out of the gate instead of
discovering it years later accidentally
I even have the curriculum developed but
short of overhauling undergraduate
course requirements I think tonight's
probably a good first step to get people
to think about fundraising more as an
opportunity and less as a dirty word if
you want to change the world you have to
know how to pay for it to do that well
you have to understand three big things
your feelings about wealth and money the
importance of building relationships and
how to ask for what you want let's start
at the top your feelings about wealth
and money what is your relationship to
money money is complicated it makes
everyone squeamish it makes everyone act
kind of weird anyone who's ever had to
split the check after dinner with
friends can tell you this and imagine
what it was like you know before venmo
to help people learn how to raise money
you have to help them understand their
deal with money because everybody has
baggage grow up poor baggage grow up
rich baggage mad or envious that other
people have more money than you baggage
I think people with money are smarter
than you
baggage feel guilty that you have more
money than other people that's some
first-class baggage still baggage people
it's still baggage so whatever your deal
is with your baggage you have to
reconcile it if you're gonna be able to
ask for money and here's a little tip
about asking people for money the only
difference about really wealthy people
in us is that they have more money than
us that's it don't overcomplicate it
they come with their own baggage when
you think about how to do this work it's
important to remember that money makes
the world go around you hear that all
the time but it's true whether you're a
non-profit for-profit or you pay your
own bills we often feel like
talking about it is this icky
embarrassing ugly thing but it's just
money and it's a fact of life so how you
feel about it directly affects how you
approach it like everyone else when I
started out in this work I had to
examine and understand my own feelings
about wealth and money and I had to
learn how to separate them from how I
feel about raising money for important
causes how I feel about asking for money
to help people do good work in the world
is not the same as how I feel about
asking for money for myself this is an
important distinction when I go and talk
to someone I'm not asking them to pay my
mortgage I'm giving them an opportunity
to invest an idea that's gonna change
the world for the better
why should I feel bad about that if you
want to be good at raising money you
have to be able to reframe the ask both
for yourself and for other people as an
opportunity next you have to get
prepared to build some relationships
people give to people they don't just
give to ideas and if they don't believe
in the person running the place you're
already dead in the water this is true
whether you're in stocks or venture
capital politics or nonprofits building
a relationship with people takes work
you have to care about more than just
what you want or need you have to also
value what someone else wants or need I
know it's a shocking terrible idea
but oftentimes closing gifts is
understanding the person more than it's
important to know the product and if you
think building a relationship with with
people takes work build in a
relationship with someone you're asking
for money from takes work and it takes
home work have you done any research do
you have any idea what they care about
do you know why they should invest in
your work can you answer that question
in less than 30 seconds if you can't the
meetings gonna be it's gonna be pretty
rough and the answer can't be because
they're super rich and they live in your
zip code when you talk to people and
understand what they care about it has
to be in person fundraising is
relational it's not transactional and
you have to ask them questions when I
sit down with the donor it goes
something like this
hi thanks so much for seeing me how have
you been
did you guys go anywhere fun over
holiday nice I love Mexico do you always
go to the same place oh that's awesome
are those your kids they're so cute how
old are they where are they in school oh
that's a great school are you guys very
involved there
your spouse is on the board how's that I
bet it's a ton of work how do you guys
meet oh it's Santa Clara that's awesome
are you super involved in the alumni
network oh that's so interesting where
do you guys live again oh that's great
is that your boat I literally go through
all of these things right and you know
why because guess what I know now I know
they're out a hundred and twenty grand a
year in schooling for the next 12 years
right spouse is on the board of the kids
school I know they're out 100k probably
it's a six-figure they're both involved
in their school alumni and that's
probably 25k they told me they live on
the Upper East Side I can look up their
apartment online and I can find out what
their mortgages and I know they own a
second home in Mexico oh and they own a
boat which is like funny money right so
what I now understand is true what I now
understand is that their thousand dollar
gift is probably more of a starter gift
and I should be thinking about ways to
to help them partner with us and invest
in a more meaningful way
I know this sounds a tad mercenary I'm
not confused about how it sounds but
here's what I want to tell you because
this is the part that all my clients
always want to skip because they think
it's the fluff and it's not important if
you don't understand what they care
about and what they value how are you
ever gonna be able to tell them about
your work right I want them to fund our
work I do but I also want them to have a
really meaningful experience as a donor
so that they feel like we're partners
and not they're not an ATM right so it's
important to ask the questions because
the more you know about them and you
know what they value the more you can
steer the conversation in a direction
about your work that will resonate for
them and once you get past the get to
know you part you get into the fun stuff
like why are you philanthropic at all
right why do you invest in new ideas do
you want giving back to be a value you
pass on to your children can we help you
do that it's really awesome it's
meaningful and remember it's a
conversation it's not a
cross-examination it's not an interview
don't walk in there and tell them
everything you already know about them
because you did your research you don't
get extra points for knowing how to use
Google it's 75 percent them talking 25
percent you listening it's better to be
a good listener than a good showman and
once you understand what they care about
you can talk to them about what you care
about right you can tell them about you
now when you do this don't get too deep
into the weeds or you'll lose them it's
a lot like when I sit down with guys in
finance right and I say you know how's
work I'm looking for like a thumbs-up
thumbs-down but what I get sometimes is
like a long just description of how the
markets are trending and my brain leaves
my body and starts to think about what
time I'd ride cleaner closes like I
don't have capacity for that and they
don't have capacity for that level
detail of our work if they want it
they'll ask you the questions it's it's
this this thing that happens over and
over because I here's an example I
worked with the CEO once and I was hired
to teach him how to talk to human people
like a human person it was a very
difficult job so he kept getting great
donor meetings and he wasn't closing any
gifts and I could not figure out what
the problem was so finally I was like
I'm just gonna come with you it's gonna
be great so I went with him to meetings
and what would happen was he was getting
into such detail with the donors that
their eyes were glazing over and then
after he was done with his 15 minute
pitch they literally would say this
happened like three times in a row god
that sounds great congratulations keep
up the good work and that was the
meeting which was obviously not the
outcome we were looking for so he
couldn't understand what I was trying to
say to him that I finally like in an act
of sheer desperation was like you know
what I love I love NASA
I love NASA
I think it is unbelievably amazing we
have figured out how to get a person to
the moon I think it's awesome I think
the idea of getting someone to the moon
and they walk on the moon and got I love
rocket ships I love rocket ships rocket
ships are amazing but if you start to
tell me about the rocket ship and how it
gets to the moon and the math and the
science equations on how the rocket ship
gets to the moon I promise you I will
hang myself with my own hair I was like
that is not how you tell people about
your work what is the need like what's
the point right how do you address the
need why are you better at it than
anybody else and what can they do to be
what can you do to make it about them
right how can they help you get to the
moon
that's the good stuff if you're able to
do that you're probably ready to make
the ask now I don't expect everyone to
be super excited to ask people for money
that's why development is an actual
profession and not an awkward hobby
naturally great fundraisers love people
they can and will talk to anyone they
can find common ground with anyone
they're your friends that talk to people
in the elevator or at the grocery store
they believe in the work required to
both build relationships and keep them
and they naturally have a high tolerance
for rejection but I don't expect
everyone to be a natural and you don't
have to be a natural to raise money you
just have to respect the people in the
process and do the work will you
reconcile your baggage will you commit
to build relationships if you will
you're ready to make the ask and the ask
is oftentimes as simple as using the
phrase would you consider would you
consider becoming a monthly donor would
you consider increasing your support to
$100 would you consider investing in our
work at the $1,000,000 level would you
consider does a couple of awesome things
one it gives the donor and easy way to
out like they can say no without it
being yes now and two it gives you a
second ask well what would you consider
it's good right when you do this
remember you're not asking for yourself
you're asking on behalf of all of the
people you serve or are touched by your
genius this isn't a personal favor right
feel proud of the ask it's incredible
that you do this work don't try to be
someone you're not you're gonna go to
these meetings and think you need to Big
Shot it be yourself authenticity matters
nobody likes a phony just be yourself
and please please don't torpedo your own
ask what I mean by this is don't walk
into the meeting and say I had an IDI
that did this all the time I stopped
inviting him he'd say we're not here
today to ask you for money yes we are
that's exactly why we're literally
that's why we're here today don't do
that don't say whatever you can do to
help that is hands down the fastest way
to get the smallest possible gift
someone thinks they can give you and get
away with not kidding and don't take it
back once you've made the ask would you
consider supporting us at the $10,000
level or the five or the two or one you
know what take the year off you're the
best thanks don't do that ask the
question wait til ten count to ten
before you speak again keep your face
like this
they are grown-ups they have all the
power in this situation they can answer
the question don't take it back which
brings me to my favorite don't ask don't
get if you don't make an actual ask no
one will give you actual money and if no
one gives you actual and money you
actually can't do anything with it it's
very simple don't ask don't get listen I
would love to live in a world or we
didn't have to ask people for money to
do important work that will change
people's lives I would love to not have
to teach people how to make a case for
the importance of feeding and housing
and educating people but this is the
world that we live in and if we're
committed to doing this work and doing
it well we have to be as committed to
the art of funding this work as we are
the art of executing that I'm going to
repeat that because I think it's really
important we have to be as committed to
the art of funding our work as we are to
the art of executing it and it at its
core the art of funding the work means
that we have to truly believe that the
purpose and the privilege of our work is
to provide people with an extraordinary
way to use their wealth that will change
people's lives it's an opportunity
because at its core that's what it is
how great is that thank you
[Applause]